[Music]
i'm lauren zima at the race to erase at
mass gala at the Beverly Hilton where
Maksim Chmerkovskiy and Peta Murgatroyd
finally got a date night out for the
first time since becoming parents they
told us all about what it's been like
you've kind of been in baby land right
yeah we've been in baby land no I was so
looking forward to tonight happiness and
repairing hair makeup and dresses for
like I know a couple of weeks getting
ready and then the worst thing happened
my dress Berg my whole zipper as Max is
doing the outer strength and so he
actually sewed me into this tonight look
at where it broke you can't even tell I
think she deserves a night out for sure
you know I didn't want to leave baby
though I was like how much have you seen
him change since becoming a dad there's
nothing sexier there's nothing more
beautiful than seeing you man you know
fall in love with your child even more
every day so it's the best it's amazing
it's amazing he's like he's a little
person now he has some specific things
you know not like genetic baby but he's
got kids this particular baby and it's
just really fun to see them become human
and become people with their own
characters and I don't know I'm just
excited to see what he's gonna end up
being I mean will he be a dancers I mean
if he wants to yeah I'm not gonna push
him into anything
I think maybe some sort of like
high-paying I don't know
athletics me Merrill yeah undergo but oh
yeah cuz you don't have to wear helmets
have you seen her change she's fully
first and foremost a mom and you know I
can't ask for anything pointing more
than that it's it's been amazing you
know it's been but you know we try to
maintain on and off in our everyday life
too and not just be you know focused on
the child it was a little crazy first
couple of months yeah but I think we got
a hang of it
adjusting to do I mean just with your
schedule alone as a person as a human
being I mean I was running back and
forth a side identity was six weeks
after giving birth so it was it was a
race to see who can get home first to
feed him well I've been blown away by
you - I mean how gorgeous you look
playing I don't know is it all that
it was hot I'm going lie it was it was
difficult that doctor
[Music]